Fabi a strategic decision to ice the
game early on with white pieces how did
you come to that conclusion
uh well normally I would have
um liked to play at least a little bit
of course the draw is is a good result
in the last round considering the
torment situation but
um I don't know I'll try to say this
delicately I mean it's a big day for
Levon and I didn't think it would be I
thought it would be wrong for me to to
play this game that was also a part of
the reason for this so I I just I just
thought okay draw make sense from every
point of view absolutely and well a
short day for you let's talk about this
game because you're probably interested
in this one as well how the USS uh raise
opening
oh I think this is a
in general I'm happy with this how how
the opening is turning out for Jeffrey
okay of course why does it better I'm
sure he'll try to press this for a very
long time but it's a very solid position
and Jeffrey
uh I mean he has experience in these
lines he's been he even played this with
a similar line with with white against
Wesley earlier in the tournament
very difficult for white to get any sort
of edge here I mean you have like the
tiniest
tiniest development Advantage with white
I guess I mean the bishop on D7 is a bit
awkward but uh usually I played this
with black and Sonic a few years ago so
more or less same position
um it's a very very tiny extra white and
very solid for black was your decision
also based on the fact that Ray was
facing a player that hasn't lost a
single game in this tournament
no again my decision was not really
based mostly on the tournament situation
uh it just conveniently worked out that
the tournament situation is kind of a
draw was also good for me
um but uh
but yeah it wouldn't have changed
anything for me no matter who Ray was
playing that makes a lot of sense guys
any questions for our leader absolutely
Pappy well first of all congratulations
on a very fine tournament a very fine
performance but you yourself have said
it Fabi the disrespectful U.S
championships coming to a close uh give
us your thoughts as a player about these
uh disrespectful U.S championships okay
but what can you say I mean it's uh it
culminated yesterday didn't it with the
beginning I I'm I've never seen anything
like this it's like uh I think maybe the
tournament is quite long also and uh
people are starting to go a bit nuts
I mean I I just couldn't wrap my head
around this moment
um
when Sam
what's your read on the whole situation
what do you think actually happened
there well we kind of were told what
happened right that the king's has his
side no but this was also corroborated
by Arbiters
that these Kings have loose tops the
crowns are loose I didn't notice but
apparently that's a thing and the only
thing is like why at that specific
moment did Sam decide to take the king
off the board and it wasn't his move
yeah it was hans's move he he
decapitated it and then he threw it I
called the Lord
I've never seen this before actually I
want I have a question do you remember
when your king was disrespected as well
do you remember any moment when your
king was actually in trouble I would put
it this way thrown out of the board not
on not in chest in the chest sense
woody woody resigning on your behalf on
move one yeah well okay this was a long
time ago
I'm not very long long time ago I'm not
very superstitious but a lot of chess
players are and they they might have
gotten like I didn't care so much but a
lot of chess players might have been
really pissed off
if someone resigned on there be happy
for the game yes but look at also Magnus
face in the pictures yeah but the thing
is Woody is such a
like eccentric individual right I mean I
I only met him briefly but he's he's so
interesting
and so unusual that uh didn't surprise
me that something like this happened
um but he is also a genius I mean like
as an actor it's just amazing
exactly yes no just I remember this
funny moment and like I tried to
remember something connected to the king
and suddenly this moment came to my mind
in London 2018 match yeah but it still
wasn't decapitated yeah I agree yes he
had it I I just know why the why the
crosses are kind of little peg-shaped
because it very often happens that they
do snap
and so then the idea is it's kind of
easy to replace them
but
I can't do this any other any other
things about this disrespectful
update about the Kings yeah so after
yesterday right every individual King
was glued on
individual Crown was glued onto the king
very carefully
so this doesn't happen again it is to
make sure for the last round I guess uh
and this is what we're discussing
yesterday's 12th game Hans was thinking
about what his move was and then Sam
just picked up his King and then
beheaded the black king announces like
hey man give me back
and life also looks uh you can ask this
line is amazing Sam also looks a bit
guilty like he was caught doing
something very naughty
Sam looked very confused in that hole
time and time again and still still pick
up things were you there at that moment
by the way no no you'd already left yes
okay
you can enjoy it I mean the game was
interesting from my point of view
because Sam was plus two and okay he was
never
and close to winning that game but if he
had won the time he would have gone to
plus three so right so I was kind of uh
curious about that game from a purely
tournament standpoint right exactly yeah
waiting for the result of Ray Robson
games
yeah thank you very much uh uh baby and
sorry sorry last question if you ever
played a playoff with uh Ray did you
ever get into a tiger
assorted Blitz Games right but never
play and some rapid games some online
shots but never play off are you going
to get prepared now what are you going
to do no okay I mean I'm going to follow
the end of the the tournament and see if
I'll need to prepare and if so then then
I will of course but I'm not gonna
prepare for something which may or may
not happen okay
okay thank you for very much Fabio thank
you for the interview still uh what what
a tournament